- Here on our show we
wanna turn the spotlight
on some women and young ladies,
who have paved their own way to success.
They are fearless.
They are resilient.
They are wild flowers.
And we are so happy to introduce you
to our very first of many
wild flowers to come,
skateboarding sensation, Sky Brown,
has set her goals high literally,
and is said to become one of
the world's youngest Olympians
at just 12 years old.
(audience cheering and clapping)
A few months ago,
a devastating fall actually
almost ended that dream,
but Sky refused to slow down
and she got right back up.
This video may be difficult
for some people to watch
because it shows Sky's actual accident.
So, be prepared and then take a look.
(skateboard rolling)
(footsteps patting)
(siren wailing)
(helicopter blade whirling)
- I don't usually post my
falls or talk about them.
Because I want people to
see the fun in what I do.
(vital signs machine beeping)
And I just want everyone
to know that, it's okay.
Don't worry, I'm okay.
It's okay to fall sometimes,
and I'm just gonna get back
up and push even harder.
(Audience clapping and cheering)
- Sky, you're so amazing.
- Thank you so much.
- Oh my gosh, how are you feeling now?
Of course, I have to ask.
- I am feeling awesome, back on skateboard
I'm surfing now too, which is
awesome 'cause I missed it.
I had my cast on, I couldn't do anything.
- I hold you in the highest regard
I really do. You're amazing.
- Thank you.
I was watching some of
your movies this morning
and you're amazing.
- Oh. Thank you Sky
and I've always thought
that girls should do what boys
do while getting to be girls
and you are the living example of that
and you have so much to teach young girls.
Another life lesson that you teach people
through what you're doing
and how you're behaving
and surging forward is when
you fall, you get back up.
- Yeah, on Instagram
everything looks perfect.
no one shows them falling.
So I thought, you know,
we all fall sometimes.
And I also wanted to show that
even when you fall, I'm
gonna push back harder.
- Actually we have an incredible video.
Can we show that you have some footage
of you getting right back up and on it.
I've got a visual for this.
(upbeat rock music)
Oh my gosh.
If that isn't the perfect visual metaphor
for how it's done Sky.
You just show such
strength and resilience.
Now, you are supposed to have
been in the 2020 Olympics.
What is it like when you have
a goal line and it gets moved?
How are you handling that?
And what's your prep for
going into 2021 Olympics?
- I was definitely bummed.
I thought that my dreams were done.
Like it was fading away
but it just gives me a longer journey
to get better and pushing even harder
and I'm excited to see
all the girls next year
and see what they got. It's gonna be cool.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Once again Sky, you have blown my mind.
You're like, you know what?
I just have now more
time to work on my craft
and get better.
Who are you?
How do you know so much?
There are monks on
mountaintops that have worked
for years to get where you are.
- Thank you.
- Oh my God.
And I just have to say that
you're just so beautiful
and so cute and pretty on the inside
and pretty on the outside
and smart in here and brave in here
and we just love you
here and you know what?
We have a little gift
for you if that's okay.
Danielle, do you mind rolling her in?
Thank you so much.
I wrote a book called Wildflower
and I too love watching
girls do what boys can do
but be girls while they're doing it
and supporting each other
and having each other's back.
So we got you a wildflower helmet
and a wildflower skateboard,
(audience cheering and clapping)
and I am sure that you
have very particular gear
that you need to do.
So if anything, consider this wall art
and a reminder that we
truly celebrate your journey
because Sky, I am forever
changed having met you
and learned about your
ability to be this wise
and this strong at 12.
- Yeah, that's what I want to do.
My dream is to inspire girls
and you can tell them, you
can do whatever boys can do.
And we're actually coming out with a song
that explains that you can be
pretty, get your nails done,
get your hair done.
You can do whatever you want
and still be tough and do sports.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Wow. Sky, keep writing music
your next song should be,
I am limitless. I can be everything.
Thank you.
And we'll be checking in if that's okay.
- Thank you so much.
(woman clapping)
- We love you Sky.
Thank you so much.
(soft techno music)